madame monsieur bonsoir l'actualité à
peu aujourd'hui dans notre région ce
qu'il est convenu d'appeler ses
quartiers d'été la grande information du
jour c'est la chaleur et le soleil qui
ont envahi paris et l'île de france
après des semaines bien maussade et
comme chaque année à pareille époque
paris devient paris plage dans ses gares
à paris plage plutôt paris bronzage car
il n'est pas question de se baigner
l'eau de la seine est en effet pollué et
le restera paraît-il jusqu'à l'an 2000
les dames sont rares sur les berges car
ce sont plutôt des messieurs en string
en short qui profite du moindre rayon de
soleil et on se met où on peut quand
l'île aux cygnes dans l'île saint louis
est surtout concentrée comme des mouches
en bas des tuileries
en effet les bords de seine ressemble à
partir de deux heures aux planches de
deauville avec des vendeurs de sandwichs
et de bière pardon plutôt des ce dakar
ces parisiens sont très attentifs à leur
silhouette
d'après la météo il y aura du soleil à
un jour son 2e au mois de juillet ainsi
entre le soleil du bord de seine et
quelques séances d'uv à vous devriez
arriver à point sur les vrais plage